regardez l'histoire par le trou de la
serrure
c'est la promesse de l'exposition de
boue et de larmes
grâce à des photographies en 3d d'époque
le spectateur sera immergé dans le
quotidien des poilus
derrière les lunettes imaginez vous à
table avec les soldats dans les
tranchées ou bien sur un champ de
bataille
grâce au relief et à la profondeur de
champ le résultat est saisissant
on a à la fois et c'est ça qui est
intéressant un mélange de photographies
de propagande on voit clairement une
mise en scène pour rassurer les familles
à l'arrière et des photographies qui
sont vraiment dans le dans l'action et
parfois qu'ils sont terribles on a voulu
donner toute leur place à ces photos
elle crée un choc créé un impact
en plus de cette expérience semble ans
et accueille de nombreux objets de
journaux d'époque
une autre manière de perpétuer le devoir
de mémoire
al'approche du centenaire de l'armistice
à l'époque 1500 habitants à peu près et
on a trente cinq jeunes dont 30 de moins
de 20 ans qui ont perdu la vie pour ça
et
quand le maire sortait on savait que
c'était pour annoncer un décès donc
c'était redouté tous les matins les
gendarmes jeunes est annoncé au maire
quelles étaient les enfants du pays qui
devaient décéder au front l'exposition
dure jusqu'au 2 novembre